just load in a cartridge press the enter
button and the foodini printer creates
an attractive edible mashed potato bowl
we're busy working on the software to
get it to print faster immediately
though it has to go fast because it's
not just about size and shape the food
also has to be served hot the foodini 3d
printer will eventually accommodate up
to six cartridges of precooked
ingredients for now it's only available
for gourmet restaurants but when it goes
into production in China everyone will
want one
well 3d food printing the way we're
doing it as natural machines is really
getting people back in the kitchens and
using fresh real wholesome ingredients
and if you think about 3d food printing
you're actually eating 3d printed food
now if you eat anything that comes out
of a food manufacturing plant because
the food manufacturing facility actually
pushes through through machines and
shapes it we're doing the same thing
except the big difference is is that
we're doing it with fresh real wholesome
ingredients that you control Europe's
first so-called Fab Cafe is only a few
streets away here guests can have
themselves scanned and while they wait
for a 3d bust of themselves to be
printed out they can relax with a coffee
inside besides themselves they can also
have other 3d products copied by own
eyes innovation and creativity are an
integral part of Barcelona's character
and that's why this has gone down so
well with the general public not just
the professionals who already have a lot
to do with high-tech but normal people
as well and different social groups
children adults and older people too
even global corporations like
hewlett-packard are in Barcelona to
invest in the latest technology it's put
money into a new 3d research centre
which is also being supported by the
Catalonian
government meanwhile evermore startups
are popping up the natural machines
company has benefited greatly from the
city's open-mindedness partly it's the
people who are pushing it but it's also
the local government and authorities
they're subsidizing it so that people on
the street come into contact with these
kinds of technologies he acts but even
better by that but the foodini can't
actually cook or bake so it's still not
clear whether customers will COFF up the
1,800 euros for this kind of 3d printer
the answer will come at the end of
September when the new product hits the
retail shelves